we're here with world champion magnus
carlson he needed some points to really
challenge the leaders and that's what he
did he just beat a very clean game
against jordan van forest magnus welcome
to the studio tell us this seemed very
clean
um yeah
i think he
misplayed the the opening or the early
middle game a little bit uh and then he
made a good decision
to
cycle the exchange that was i think
um that was i think the only chance a
little bit further right yeah um so yeah
f4 i mean b6 was was good i mean i kind
of underestimated that because i thought
after i went f4 i thought i'd just
i was just gonna roll over him um
so after after that there was quite a
bit of uh quite a bit of work um
[Music]
but i felt that i was always um favorite
to to make it in the end and absolutely
i made it you made it seem very simple
especially with the huge time advantage
you have technique was very strong
yeah i mean for once i actually played
kind of quickly and the two times that i
played quickly against dominguez as well
i actually
did did well in that that game also so
um
overall i think i've played okay until i
get in time travel and then i just
played horribly uh
so my time management hasn't been
doesn't be good but there there has been
some some improvement
i mean i lost the game i never in a
million years should it should have
should have lost definitely should have
beaten dominguez should
probably have had chances against so as
well so you know
it's
not as bad as the story suggests i feel
like i'm playing myself into
the reasonable shape so i have one more
game and then
a lot of a lot of blitz to look forward
to absolutely we have tons of blitz
ahead of us this course not that bad now
that you took that jordan you are still
within striking distance of some of the
leaders
yeah yeah i guess i'll uh i'll be um two
points behind already which is
not good but it's not a disaster so
it's still pretty early yeah we have one
more rapid games and remember 18 full
rounds of blitz well we'll let you rest
for the third round of the day thank you
magnus guys back to the studio two
remaining games thank you uh alejandro
one remaining game because